字幕: Takahiro Shimpo
校正: Hiroko Kawano
私が日本に来たのは
もう25年前ですね
最初は２年のつもりだったんですね
うちのお母さんに言ってきましたけど
あの ついつい
長くなってしまいましたね
その間はさっき
紹介があったんですけど
銀行員をやったり
研究者をやったり
今 大学教員をやってるんですけど
何回も今度こそ帰ろうと
思ったことがあります
イギリスに帰りましょう
結局残った理由はですね
まあ １つの理由はですね
２つの文化にまたがって
生活することの面白さですね
それについて今日
紹介したいと思っています
まだ はっきり覚えています
最初日本に来たときですね
伊丹空港
昔 国際空港だったんですけど
９月 まだ蒸し暑い気候だった
蒸し暑い天気
イギリスと全然違う気候
周りをみると
髪の毛が真っ黒な人たち
今日みたいにね
やっぱり外国に着いた
っていう実感が湧きました
あとはですね
一番印象深かったのはですね
周りをみて
ネオンサインがいっぱいあって
標識があって全部
色んなことが書かれてるんですね
それを見て私は突然
文字読めなくなってしまった
そういう読み書きできない人に
なってしまった
っていう印象を
すごい受けたんですね
多分普段はですね
ほとんど無視してるんですね
なんとか新発売 とか
アサヒスーパードライ
って書いてるんですけど
あの普段は無視してますね
でもいきなりその中に入っちゃうと
そのフィルタが
外されたような感じですね
その情報の多さに圧倒された
その気持ちを覚えてますね
ええ 英語で言うと
dizzy ですね
くらくらする
まあ 良い意味でくらくらするんですね
あの興奮気味で
そういう状態だったんですね
この日本語っていう暗号[を見て]
解読できれば
きっと素晴らしい世界が見えてくる と
もう新発売なんとか
とは分からないんですね
で 日本語の勉強に
取りかかりました
で 最初 意外と
日本語面白いんですね
英語と全然違う所が多いので
なかなか面白いと感じました
特に英語との関係を考えるとですね
例えば 日本語学校に行くと
英語の milk は牛乳と習います
牛乳なんですけど
コーヒーを入れた途端に
また ミルクに戻りますね
これはなかなか面白かった
あとですね
政治家のbrain っていうのは
政治家のbrain は
あなたのbrain かもしれないですね
僕のbrain かもしれない
大体 政治家のbrain ではないですね
政治家のbrain って言った場合
my car はmy car でいいんですけど
沢山の人たちがmy car に
乗ってるというのは
すごい不思議な感じがします
あとですね 漢字も頑張りました
憂鬱とか 薔薇とか
そんなどうでもいい
なんとなく こう暗号の解読に
関係する活動だと思って覚えました
で その後
日本語能力試験１級に受かりました
それでできると思ったら
ただ大学で仕事をやり始めると
本当に通用しない
ということが良く分かりました
例えば 小さい例なんですけど
どっかの会議で
「ケイ別ガイダンスはいつ開催しますか？」
っていう話になったんですね
ケイ は理学系とか
物理系とか そういう「系」なんですけど
僕の電子辞書を調べたらですね
人を「軽蔑」する
って書いてあるんですね
「軽蔑ガイダンス」
きっといじめ問題があったに違いない と
(笑)
あの しばらく勘違いし[てい]ました
まあ そういう風にですね
失敗しながら
恥ずかしい思いしながら
少しずつ使えるように
日本語覚えていきました
振り返ってみると
楽しかった
面白い経験だったんですけど
結局 長い戦い
という印象もやっぱり残りますね
で こういう風に
身を異文化に置くというのは
そういう自分の—
ここに書いてあるんですね
自分のコンフォートゾーン
から踏み出して
活動をすることになりますね
で コンフォートゾーンは何か？
っていうと
心地いい
ストレスの少ない活動の場ですね
そこ[から]踏み出すというのは
心地が悪くて ストレスが多い
そうすると
そういう風に言うと
あんまり良い印象を
受けないかもしれないんですけど
経営学とかそういうところに行くと
高く評価されますよね
やっぱり自分のコンフォートゾーン
自分の心地良いところから踏み出して
インターネットを見るとこういうのは
いっぱい載ってると思うんですけど
これは「Where the magic happens」
と書いてありますね
あの私は日本に来て
こういう風にやってるっていうのは
明らかに私のコンフォートゾーンから
離れてるんですけど
これ [私にとって全部は]
納得できない部分なんですね
私の経験とちょっと違いますね
ちょっと違う考え方から
見ていきたいと思うんです
これはIBM の創設者
トーマス・ワトソン
この言葉 この名言は
かなり気に入っています
（英語）「私は天才ではない
ただ中には得意なこともあり—
私はその得意な分野から
離れないようにしてきただけだ」
まあ要するに天才じゃない
天才ではなくて
ところどころに才能があって
その才能を活かす
っていうところですね
多くの人たちはこういう言葉に
共感できる部分が
あると思うんですけど
やっぱり こう スポット[を]
作らなきゃいけないんですね
こう同じコンフォートゾーンの中で
作るのはなかなか難しい
特に まあかなり長いこと
日本の教育システムに参加して
参加して見てきたんですけど
日本の教育レベルは高いんですね
世界で見てもレベルは
高いんですけど
多様性は少ないんですね
多様性を育てるような
システムではない
その中でみんな同じような
コンフォートゾーンを持ってることになります
その中で自分の得意分野
自分の得意スポットを見つけるのは
なかなか難しい
で これはもうちょっと
私の経験に近いような
コンフォートゾーンと
まずですね
境界はちょっとぼかして書きました
それは気分によりますね
気分によりますし
あとビール飲むと
もっとぼやけてきますよね
あとですね
こう新しい経験をして
完全にコンフォートゾーンから
踏み出してるんじゃなくて
コンフォートゾーンが形を変えながら
広がっていくっていう
そういうのは
僕の経験に近いんですね
で １つ具体的な例を
紹介したいと思います
これは私が関わってきた
大きいプロジェクト
時々ニュースに出てましたので
皆さん耳にしたことが
あるかもしれないんですが
大陸棚の—
延長した大陸棚の話ですね
これはですね
何かって言うと
まあ 海に面してる国はある程度
その海に対する
権利を主張できるんですね
当たり前なんですけど
どこまでっていうのは
なかなか決めにくい
この話は 実は15世紀まで
さかのぼりますね
その時はローマ法王がですね
体制をすぱっと２つに分けて
はい スペインとポルトガル
[に分けて]終わり
分り易くていいんですね
分り易くていいんですけど
反対する国は当然でてきます
で 色々 紆余曲折があって
最近ですね 国連が中心になって
ルールを整備してきた
そのルールに従って
色んな国が 今
自分の権利を国際的に
認めていただくような運動を始めています
実際に申請して
国連で審査委員会があって
そこで承認されれば
その国の領土に入ることになります
考え方は
かなり簡単なんですけど
陸地があって 200海里
海里って使いますけど
360 km くらい
まずこの領域はですね
この領域は 排他的経済水域になります
この下にある海底も
全部 この国の主権になります
但し こういう風に距離だけで線を引くと
それは 下に
こう地形が続いてるとか
地質が続いてるのに
そこに線を引くのは不自然な
境界になるので
それを越えるような
延長した大陸棚も認められます
私が関わったのは
この延長大陸棚の定義申請です
結構大変な
プロジェクトだったんですね
毎年100億円くらいの
予算がついてました
５年間
それを聞くとですね
消費税分だけでもいいですけど
自分の研究に使いたいなあ と
（笑）
思ったんですけど
まあ こんだけの船を動かして
潜水艦もそうですね
あとは地震計を海底に置いたり
非常に大がかりな
プロジェクトになりました
これを使って
こういう船を使って
日本近海の海底の
重力、磁性、岩石の種類
岩石の年代
色々 明らかにしてきました
今までにないような精度で
本当にきれいに
その姿が浮き彫りになってきました
ミリメートル単位で色々決めてる
科学者として 私は
海底をミリメートル単位で
決めるのはいいんですけど
プレートは年間で
数cm 動いてるので
いいのかな？
でもそれは国際法と地球学の違いだと
割り切るしかないですね
私はこの中で何をやったかって言うと
膨大なデータを集めて
申請書の形に集めなきゃいけない
申請書は国連に出すもの
英語で書かなきゃいけない
専門知識が必要
だから 私は
色んな研究者と連携しながら
この申請書の仕上げに貢献しました
で 結果なんですけど
まだ認められてない
完全に審査が終わってない部分が
あるんですけど
こういうピンクのところは
ここは日本ですね
四国 と紀伊半島
九州 これは四国海盆で
南鳥島はここにあります
こういうピンク—紫のところは
新しく認められた範囲
まあ 日本の国土の
８割くらいに相当するような
範囲が認められました
非常に大きな結果になりました
大きな結果っていうのは
海底に資源がいっぱい
眠ってるっていう
事実があるんです
今 抽出するための
そういう技術は難しいんですけど
資源っていう意味で非常に大きい
あとはですね
国境 境界
国の境界がどこにあるか
こういう風に
国際的に認めていただくというのは
要するに争わなくて決まるもの
そういう意味で非常にこれ
成果は大きいと思ってます
これが申請書です
あの 時々
半分冗談で言うんですけど
僕以外の人は誰か
読んでるんですかね？
(笑)
でも あの
審査員は少なくとも
それ言っちゃうとダメなのかな
何人かは読んでるそうです はい
まあトルストイの「戦争と平和」よりも
でっかいものになりまして
3200ページ
私にとってですね
こういう風に私 地球科学者と
政治家と話—
外務省の人たちと
話をしなきゃいけない
そして国際法の人たち
そして色んな技術の人たち
一緒に話し合って
１つの国家プロジェクト
日本の国益
国際的にもこんな大きなプロジェクトに
貢献できたっていうのは
僕にとって
非常に感慨深いものだったんですね
非常に面白かった
なぜ できたかっていうと
どういう才能っていうか
どういう経験が
必要だったかって言うと
まずイギリス人である
日本に住んでるイギリス人
日本語ができて
地球科学知識があって
あとはですね多分
雑誌の編集者の経験とか色々ある
僕はこれを目指してた
わけではないんですね
偶然 こう偶然の出会い
あるいは自分の趣味として
培った自分の得意のスポットが
たまたま ここに非常にうまいこと
はまったっていうことですね
で じゃあその
コンフォートゾーンから
踏み出して活動するっていう
それは必ずしも留学とか
僕みたいにね
海外に行く必要は
ないと思うんですけど
違う考え方を側近で見る
一番手っ取り早い
やり方だと思いますね
色んな意味でやっぱり
留学は重要だと思いますし
世界を見たら爆発的に
留学生の人数が増えています
増えてるんですけど
これは日本ですね
2012年
これは海外に行った留学生の人数
まあ １番上中国 インド
人口が多いので当たり前と言えば
当たり前なんですけど
あとはですね
韓国はこれだけ人数多いですね
で ドイツ、サウジアラビア、フランス
アメリカ、マレーシア、ベトナム と
日本はここなんです
ここですね
これを先週 データを集めてみて
本当にびっくりしました
こんなに低いという
あとですね
日本人が一番好む行き先として
アメリカがありますけど
これだけ減ってますね
10年間で半減してます
これは最後のスライドなんですけど
これは学生に時々話をします
これは数千年前
アルゼンチンにある
クエバ・デ・ラス・マノス
有名な場所なんですけど
数千年前そこに
住んでた人たちの手形ですね
これやっぱり人間の基本的な
願望の１つを表してると思うんですね
残したいんですね
私はここにいました
その証を残したい
私は昔 銀行で働いてて
年収よかったですね
おいしいレストランに行けるし
辞めたときはですね
だいぶ迷いました
でも結局大学に戻ってきたのは
こういうことに関係している
という気はします
で 自分の学生を見てると
卒業した後はどうなるか？
やっぱり教育者として
非常に気になります
見てるとですね
よく もっと暴れて欲しい
もっと限界を試して欲しいな
と思います
最近ですね国内志向っていう
若者の傾向があると言われてる
そういう関係もあると思います
私はそういう人たちをですね
是非 自分のコンフォートゾーンは
どこまであるのか認識した上で
敢えてそこから踏み出して
日本の大陸棚と同じように
拡大させて
それで ほどよくストレスを
感じながら 楽しみながら
自分の手形をしっかり
将来につけて欲しいと思います
以上です